ladies and gentlemen Billy Crystal
thank you thank you thank you well that
was extremely loud of incredibly close
thank you so much
extremely loud incredibly close that's
how my relatives are watching the show
this is this is my ninth time ninth time
hosting the Oscars
so tonight just call me warhorse we're
here at the beautiful chapter 11 theater
to celebrate a Hollywood tradition that
not only creates memories for the ages
but also breeds resentments that last a
lifetime we are part of a great industry
a great industry movies have always been
in to provide entertainment whenever we
need a place to get away from it all
it's like that great speech that James
Earl Jones made in Field of Dreams hello
sir it's that great speech when he
talked about baseball
he said that movie that baseball has
always been that during good times and
hard times and just as people turn to
baseball the movies have always been
there for us they're the place to go to
laugh to cry to question to text
so tonight enjoy yourselves because
nothing can take the sting of the
world's economic problems like watching
millionaires present each other with
golden statue you didn't think I wasn't
gonna do this did you
we got a hustle because the nine
nominated films are he won't talk don't
ask you he won't talk don't ask you but
if the artist wins he'll say Mouse in
bamboo this horses will horse because
his horse with Louisville birdie in for
divorce and now the Oscars may endorse
the famous mr. Joey
is a memory rad is a manager if caught
in a riddle
Jonah used to have much more to his
middle it's great that you shed weight
good kid if you lose tonight
I think that you should know the serving
cupcakes after the show
Scorsese owes prints and no one's in a
splint well that's you
there's no Pesci no bomb is no killing
no mob it's just to go but a truth I'd
prefer for the sequel you don't be so
hard
the kid track ahead shoot Ben Kingsley
in bed cushion Marty
what's it all about the tree of life was
deep and on malli I heard it even
freaked out God explained it
cracking up because his wife was
shacking up George is packing up he puts
the wipers gentlemen no they weren't
proposed she's kind of common toast so
it makes it hard to tell her that your
man Looney makes judea films and
independence just you she redefines a
March and a descendant five nominations
had to prove their descendants is cinema
the life and a pot Awards welcome Tony
right there the answer will be laying
George tonight Hawaiian it's a Hawaiian
I love Midnight in Paris that rich
romantic style and Owen will it was so
great as woody the Gentiles
sweat family's left all the crap that
they slept yes the southland they gave
birth to the hell
the girl was white she saw them flying
and rolled
now they had a voice they had a choice
they chose this shouting
it's the Oscars so kick off your shoes
it's a party for one for the rest it's
the burn
thank you so much we'll have a great
show here the presenter first award
two-time Oscar winner mr. Tom Hanks
you